そういうことに基づいて大失敗を成功に変えるプロセス
1 失敗を認める  2 その原因を見出す
3 成功を現実的に仮定する
これは大事ですよ 現実的に仮定しなくちゃいけないんです
だから無知な人にできません
この現実的 具体的っていうことですね
とっても仏教ではもう大事なんです
4 成功になる原因条件を見出す
まあ成功は現実化した
現実的にイメージしたところで
それのために 例えば明日明後日お客さんが来る
それだったら綺麗な花で家を飾っておきたいという
それではっきりしていますね
しかし このつぼみは明日咲くでしょうと
あるいは今日咲くでしょうと
そうすると明後日はもうほとんどもうダメになっていると
あ 困ったな どうしようかと
それで現実的にはもう花咲くのはそっと 1 日ぐらい遅らせましょうと
花咲くのを遅らせると思って花を針金で縛っておいても意味がない
それは原因じゃないんです
それでなぜ花が咲くのかというと
温度と太陽の光とかね
その 2つでしょうに ではそれ変えておきましょうと
冷やしておくと 光は与えないようにすると
それで条件が変わったんだから
もうつぼみが咲くのはもうそこで遅くなるんです
そういうふうに具体的ということが大事なんですね
それで原因を見いだす
5 努力して原因と条件を揃う
6 期待した結果は自然に現れる
だから結果に気にするなってはいけません
この自然に現れるということは大事なんです
結果に引っかかる必要ないんです
条件揃っちゃえば もう勝手に結果が出ているんです
みんな失敗するのは結果ばっかり気にするんですよ
これって完璧な無知な行為なんです
我々があの権利あるのは条件を変えることだけなんです
法則変えられません 世の中で
しかし 我々には原因と条件をちょこちょこといじることできます
で 私たちはやるべきなのは原因と条件をちょこちょこちょこちょこといじることなんです
それをいじると あの流れがそれなりに変わっていくんですよ
だから結果はあの自然に現れるということはしっかりと覚えておかないと
これ以上も以下もありません
簡単でしょ 項目は 6つしかないんです
それはもう大成功 大失敗
大成功に変える方法なんです
それから一つ一つ説明していきます
1 失敗を認めるということはどういうことでしょうかと
認めてくない気持ちは心の中に潜んでいるんですよ
これはもうほとんどの人間
そうなんですよ 稀な人間なんですよ
失敗を認めるの だからお釈迦様は言うんです
自分が何か失敗したら
堂々とそれを認めることはものすごい立派な人間であると
人間の中で指導者であって
模範であって 尊敬するべきものであると
しかし これ稀なんですよ
失敗を認める人っていうのは
だからブッダの世界ではもう我々もだらしない
もうかっこ悪くて 性格が最悪で
もうもう話にならない人間なんですけど
一旦仏弟子になったところで
もうとことん叩き込むのは
もう自分の過ち 自分の失敗っていうのは一言も文句言わずに認める習慣なんです
どちらがどれほどそれきついかというと
反対する方法さえも教えていないんです
認めませんと だから出家は大体月 ２回ぐらい集めて菩薩儀式というものをやるんだけど
あれは何のことなくお互いに認め合うだけで終わっちゃうんです
私はもうあれ あれこれごちゃごちゃいろんな過ち
過ちをしたんだから これを報告しますと
そしたら認めますか？と
認めますと では頑張ってください
それで終わりである それで相手方もまた同じことを言うんです
年上年下関係ないんです
お互い それで認めたところで
ではお釈迦様の出家に対する憲法ありますからね
それをありがたく一部読みましょうと
これはお互いの過ちを認め合って
自分たちはもうしっかりした人間になることに覚悟をしているんだという清らかな状態できたならば読み上げるんであって
では読んではいけないという
ということは ブッダの教えは言ってもいけないという性格悪かったらという
そこまで厳しいんです
そこでその前置きの儀式終わって
お互い認め合って もう謝り合って
それからまあちょこちょことプラティモクシャというテキストを読むんです
それで終わりと 別に何のおもしろいことでもないんです
すごくつまらない儀式ですけど
でも意味は生命に対する素晴らしい意味なんです
失敗を認めなさいよと
それで成長するんだよ
それで悟れますよと だから出家の人々には
まあそこまで月 2回やりなさいというところまで
そうすると毎日同じことで面白くないでしょうと思っちゃうとダメなんです
お客さんが今日来るんだからね
こんなもう毎日毎回同じ
これ先月も聞きましたから
私はやめますよとかね
それやっちゃいけないんです
お客さんが来るんだったら
その人を止まっと終わらせなくちゃいけないんです
それぐらいあれにはもう神経を使わなくちゃいけないんです
行って何かやるかというと
別になんてこともないんです
お互いに賛美するだけで終わるんです
互いに ですから 認めるということは大事なことなんです
これが私の失敗でしたと
他人に言われると落ち込んだり
怒ったり 攻撃をしたり
自分を誤魔化して正当化しようとしたりする
一番気持ち悪いことっていうのは
我々の過ちはいつでも他人がガチャガチャ言うでしょうね
そうするとすごく落ち込んだりする
怒る 攻撃する あるいは誤魔化して正当化する
最悪状態なんです 認めることによって人は大きくなるのに
自分で失敗したと認めたくはなくなる
でもみんな困りますから
周りが言っちゃうんですよ
例えば 俗世間でやる法律制度はいつでもそうなってますね
検察側がいて とことん訴えて訴えて
自分たちが苦労して証明するんです
この人はこの犯罪を起こしましたと
犯罪している人は徹底的にいえ
違います いえ 違いますよと攻撃する
弁解する だから仏教的に言えば
もうもうとことん人が堕落する
やり方なんです いわゆる文化的な尊い社会じゃないんです
すごく質が悪くて 性格が悪くて
成り立たない もう平和っていう調和
平和っていうのは微妙にでもない世界なんです
だから鬼同士なんですね
だからそういうふうに法律
システムなどなどができているんです
仏教的じゃないんです
まあ仏教的だったら 自分が犯罪を起こしたら
すぐたちまちそれを認めるんです
認めて 堂々と適切な処理を受けるんです
そうなると 被害者たちにも怒り
憎しみもなくなっちゃうし
もう誰にも何の嫌な気持ちもなく
国のお金もなくなることなく
無事解決するんですよ
といっても 失敗したら
まあ私はもう犯罪でも起こったらすぐ言いますよと自白
自白というんですか しますよという性格の人は
面白いことに犯罪を起こしません
もっと立派なことをやろうとするんであって
だらしないことをやろうとはしないんです
だから初めから人格者なんですよ
だからそれっていうのは人類に簡単に習うことできます
それほど何も要りません
法律もあれもこれも要りません
ただ自分が人格者になるだけのことなんです
だから仏教でいう子育ての仕方はね
そういうところは子供に教えてあげるんですよ
立派な人格者になること
たとえ子供であっても
人格者でなきゃダメやと
だから子供ですから わからないこといっぱいあるんだから
いろいろ失敗はあるかもしれませんだけど
それは堂々と私がやったんだよと
言いなさいよと それで子供が
例えば絨毯を何かお醤油こぼしちゃったならば
まあ絨毯はなかなか元に戻せないし
大変な損でしょうし で
親がカンカン怒っちゃう
子供はキャーキャーとそれで弁解したり
だってお兄ちゃんがとかね
あるいはなんでお母さんがそちらにこれを置いておくんでしょうかとかね
それだったらもう最悪の人間として大きくなるんです
だから自分の失敗はもう何のことなく
お母ちゃんこうなったんだよとかね
それでお母ちゃん ああそうですかね
では 2人でこれ綺麗にしましょうねとかね
言うと 叱ることも何もなく
穏やかな平和で調和で成長していくんですよ
だから 立派な人格っていうのは
やっぱり小さい時は叩んでおいた方が
叩いておいた方がやりやすいんです
認めたくない気持ちは
自分を過剰に評価していることか
自我中心的かなどですね
認めたくない ごまかしたいということは
自分を過剰に評価して
私は完璧やというように
あるいはもう世の中どうなってもいいやという
えらい自我中心的で気にするもんか
そんなのは そんなのはとか
あとは電車に座って 堂々ともう両手を開けて新聞を読んでいて
これでもう三人分を取っていて
もう携帯やっていて エスカレーターいるでしょうし
突然みんな下がっていくと
いきなりもう携帯を開けて始まるんですね
そのまま流れが止まって気にしない
世の中のこと 電車に降りる時でも
ドアの付近に立っていて
これでやって 自分がメールを送ってから降りるんですね
後ろたくさんの人々が待っているのに
降りるために それは気にしない
気にするもんかと だからもうもう人格っていうのは微妙にもひとかけらもないんですよ
だからそれっていうのは自我中心的っていうことです
そういう方々はただ自分のことしか考えていない
自分完璧やと思っている人々はまた別として
日本では完璧というところはそれほど大体見えませんだけど
自我中心的なんですね
自分 自分 自分 自分 それしか考えてないんです
それで結果としてどうなるのかって
ものすごく寂しくて生活しなきゃいけけないんですよ
仲間がないんです だから携帯依存症になってるんです
認める人は勇気がある
明るい 合理的な人間です
自分なんて謝っちゃ認めるって勇気があるんです
明るいんです 合理的です
そこでかつてやった悪いことなんかは
もう犯罪までもうもう何のことなく淡々と言う人々いるでしょう
もうびっしり信頼した方がいいんです
私は人を殺したこともあるんだよとかね
そう 何のことなく言う人っていうのはもう信頼できるんです
逆に怒って脅しに言う場合は別ですけど
2番目 その原因を見いだす
失敗した原因を 失敗を認めない人も原因を探すが
それは原因ではなく言い訳になるんです
そこで失敗しちゃったんですけど
認めたくない あれあれあれ
なんでこうなったのかとかは探すんだけど
あの人々は原因を探してないんです
言い訳を探している だから
世の中で誰でもいろんな仕事
会社 いろんな家庭の中とかね
失敗したところで あれ
なんでこうなったんだ
なんでこうなったんでしょうかとか
なんで子供が不良になったんでしょうかとかは調べてはするんだけど
見つからないでしょうね
そういう人々は言い訳を探しているんです
逃げ道を探しているんです
だから仏教的な原因探すこと探しじゃないんです
失敗を乗り越えることはできないですから
そういう人々は 失敗を客観的に認めることができる人は
瞬時にその原因を探し出さなくてはならないんです
だから自分が失敗する
あ これは私の失敗だと
それだけだったら なんでこんな失敗したんでしょうかと自分で見ればいいんです
もうごまかしじゃないんだからね
私が失敗しました それは何でしょうかね
言うと本当の原因が出てくるんです
だから認めなきゃダメなんです
とにかく 失敗に 原因はなんですけど
たくさんあるんです だから一個だけではなくて
たくさんあるんですよ
これ全部探して出してほしいんですよ
今日はその説明ないと思いますけど
まあ自分の自分個人の原因もあるし
それは自分で管理できるし
周り環境の原因もあるし
自分にも周りにもどうにもならない原因もあるし
そういう 3種類大体あるんです
まあ例えばもう試験にしっかり勉強して
しっかり訓練を受けて
まあ合格はもう 99%確率だよと思っていても
電車に乗ったところで人身事故起こる可能性もありますしね
それでもう合格っていうのは失敗になっちゃうし
その場合はまあ自分にどうすることもできない原因だからね
それでも発見したら 今度はそうならないようにと気をつけることはそれでもできるんです
失敗の原因 何にでもやり方というものはあるので
それは理解しなかった場合
どんなことにもやり方があるんですよ
このワンパターンでできるわけじゃないんです
これ 無常を知らない人々には難しいんです
能力なくなっちゃうんです
本当に仏教的になってくると
もう何でもできるようになるんですよ
しっかりとブッダの教えを信じる
実践する人間になったら
もう何でもできるようになるんです
それで周りからすごくやみられるんですよ
なんであんた何でもできるんでしょうか？とかね
初めて見たものでも すぐまあこういうことではないか
すぐわかるんです それでどういうことでしょうかね
それってのはワンパターンで生きてないっていうことなんです
ワンパターンでは生きていられません
どんなものにもやり方があります
それでやることっていうのはものすごい複数でしょうね
無数でしょうね というわけで
まあそのその現場で そのその仕事でやり方があります
これがわからない人は失敗します
まあ冗談言いますけど
晩ご飯食べる食べ方で朝ごはん食べると失敗なんです
晩ご飯は晩ご飯で 朝ご飯は朝ご飯で
それただのご飯なんですけど
それでもやり方は違うんです
服を着るっていうことは毎日やってますけど
毎日これこれ目的によって違うんですけど
着方は 布団に入る時の服の着方と結婚式に行く時の服の着方違うでしょうに
間違ってみてください
置き換えてみてください
どうなるのかと それだったらすごい失敗でしょうね
寝間着でね 結婚式に行ったといえば
披露宴に行ったと 披露宴のところじゃなくて病院に運ばれる可能性はもう
そういうことで あの 物事にやり方がありまして
頭が混乱して そこはできなくなったところで失敗になるんですね
それから 欲 怒り 競争心
嫉妬 落ち込みなどの感情に心が汚染されている
これって欲があって 心がいつでも汚染されているんだから
智慧が機能しないんですね
感情により心が頑固で硬くなっているんですね
感情っていうのは妄想から生まれるもので
怒り 嫉妬っていうのは妄想の結果なんです
しょうがなく怒っているわけじゃないんです
自分の妄想で怒っているんです
世の中が悪いんだから
自分が嫉妬深い人間になったっていうのはありえないんです
自分の妄想の結果なんです
それで心が硬くなるんですね
動かないんですね そうするとやり方発見できないんです
それで明るさがなくなっちゃうんですね
楽しみを感じつつ仕事をしない
これでも失敗するんです
とにかくやってやり投げでやる
...これってよく能力ある人々の世界でもよく見えるんですよ
能力あるんだからできるんだからやるんだけど
やり投げなんです どうせできるんだからって
どうなるかって ストレス溜まっちゃって疲れて
自分にとって単純にできる仕事なのに
なんでそんなに疲れてるんですかね
だからそれはものすごい失敗なんですよ
だから自分の仕事は楽しみを感じつつやらなくちゃいけないんです
集中力も落ち着きもない場合も失敗する
判断能力がない場合は失敗する
自分の仕事に大事な意義があると思わないので
やり投げのアプローチ
それも失敗する 我々はどんな仕事をしても
ただ紙を折ることになっても
雑巾でテーブルを拭くことになっても
やり投げはダメなんです
意義があるんですよ どんな仕事にも
投げやり  投げやりでしたっけ
じゃあ変えてください
投げやり状態で だから我々すごい気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分の朝から寝るまでのすべてもやっていることには意味があるんです
布団を出していくことでも大事なことでしょうに
投げやりでやるんじゃないんです
投げやりでやるとすっごくストレス溜まっちゃって
疲れちゃって 失敗ばかりになるんです
仕事は失敗しなくても
自分が疲れてるんだったらもう失敗なんです
期待は具体的ではなく
妄想的 それから期待っていうのは
えらっ妄想的になってくるともう失敗するに決まっている
妄想の実現化できませんから
具体的な期待の実現化だけできます
あるいは自分に自信がない
他に対して慈しみではなく
怒り 差別などある場合も
もう人生失敗する 我々の仕事っていうのは
どんなことでも人間に関係あるんです
部屋の掃除したっても
これは人間に関係あるんだから
掃除した部屋で人間が住んでいるんだから
だから人間に関係ない仕事っていうのはないんです
ですから 人々に対して
慈しみがないとうまくいかないんです
それで 3番目の項目に入ります
成功を現実的に仮定するという3番目
欲望的に 夢などにはリミットがない
欲望だったらいくらでも作られる
頭の中の仕事だから 来た夢などにもいくらでも作れますからね
でも実現できんだからね
夢欲望を追うと 観念と妄想の渦巻きに吸い込まれる
もう引き継がれなくなるんです
自分という気持ち 自我意識を捨てて
自分がいないという態度で気がするんです
企画するんです 企画は成功したければ
自分というものをいないという過程でやるんです
自分が割り込むと それで固定ということがね
変わらない何かということが出てくるんです
まあ淡々と企画するだけですよ
その時はどちらでも変わりますよと
こちら変わったらこちらこういう風に変えますと
あちらも変わってしまえば
そちらもこういう風に変わりますよと
だから まあ何か計画的にやっている時は
このまあ Aプランでいきましょうと B
プランでいきましょうと冗談で言ったりする場合ありますけど
それでそれもダメだったら
じゃあスリープランにするしかないんだと
スリープランって何ですか？と
まあ考えてないんだけど
これから考えるんだと
というふうなものだったらうまくいきますよ
プラン一しかなければうまくいけないんです
実現は可能か必要かという 2つの基準に基づく企画しても基準 2つあります
実現が可能か？ 2番目必要か
実現が可能であっても必要でない場合は
そういう計画は要りませんし
まあそういうふうな感じで ３番目を整理するんです
なんで 4に 5になっちゃった
何か間違っている  4 は落ちてますかね
知らない あるいは   えっ
4 は成功になる原因条件を見出すんです
あ それ落ちてますね どうしますか？じゃあそれを普通に言います
あの 成功に必要な原因を計画立てて
それからこの計画はどうすればうまくいくのかというね
例えば まあ計画では文章を書く必要がある場合は
それはあの人なら真面目な文章
昨日聞いた文章を書けると
それでいくつか買い物もしなくちゃいけない
あ あの人なら買い物上手ですから
すぐ探し見つけていいものを買うでしょうと
そういうふうなことなんです
それほど難しいことじゃないんです
成功するためには まあどんな条件
どんな原因 揃えちゃえばいいのかとかね
で それ 5番目はまず失敗した原因をなくす
もう何か明るく楽しく仕事をこなす
何やってもすごく明るく楽しくやらなくちゃいけないんです
どんな仕事にも意味があるんです
結果に足を引かれることは危険ですね
だから結果ということは考えてはいけないのです
考えた途端 もう足がもう控えています
結果じゃないんです 自分たちの仕事なんです
大事なのは それを明るく楽しくこなすと
結果は勝手に来るんです
結果に導く過程に集中するんです
結果ではなくて その仕事に関わる様々な原因
また その仕事がスムーズに進む条件などに徹底的に気をつける
だからかなり努力しなくちゃいけないんですよ
気楽にできるわけじゃないんです
世の中で結果という固定したものはありません
結果は最終的にたどり着いて止まるところではない
...かという危険な錯覚があります
まあみんなに危険な錯覚がありますよ
まあ結果出したと まあそれで終わりと
そんなものは世の中にないんです
最終ゴールというもの
世の中ではないんです
まあ仏道でしか まあ涅槃というね
解脱という最終ゴールがありますけど
それ以上はないんです
どんな結果出ても 次はどうするのかということはあるんですよ
だから終わらない旅なんですよ
なのに 結果 結果 結果 結果ばっかり考えちゃうと
これは妄想になっちゃうんですね
すべて瞬間瞬間変わっていく現象なのです
結果ばかり気にする人には
流動的な現象に対して正しい理解がありません
だから何でも瞬間瞬間変わっていく世界だから
この原因をじっと調べて
ちゃんとたどり着いて進むしかないんですよ
まあ勝手にこれは結果
これは結果と言ったっても結果じゃないんですよ
料理作っている間では
あの完成した料理を終わったことが結果であって
出来上がったことは でもそれ結果じゃないでしょうね
それからまた進まなくちゃいけないんだから
食卓の料理用意したら
まあ結果は食べることでしょうね
でも食べたことは結果ですかね
それから次のことがあるんだから
だから我々は人生そのようにもう終われなく流すしかないんです
結果 結果と思っちゃうと
もうそれでもう混乱してダメになっちゃうんです
物は固定していると思うことは邪視ですね
間違っている考え方です
間違った思考で行う行為は
期待する結果は出しません
だから何か結果っていうふうに固定した概念があると
これは邪視なんです だったら結果出ないんです
失敗するんです 考え方おかしいんだから
結果なんかあるわけないでしょうと
全部流れるんだよと 流れの中に正しく流れるしかないんです
それが成功ということなんです
必ず期待は 何でしたっけ？はずれの逆効果になるのです
期待はずれの逆効果になるんですね
もう邪視でやっちゃうと
皆失敗するのはこの正しい法則を知らない
気にしないからなのです
世の中で人間というのはみんな失敗者なんですけど
みんな失敗者になっているのは
この結果なんかはあるわけじゃない
こんな固定したものはない
ただの流れですよと 結果結果と言いたければもう言ってもいいんだけど
大したことはないんだと
料理はよく出来上がったことは結果だと言いたければ言ってもいいんだけど
食べる人々はもう食べられなくなったら別にその結果は無駄になるでしょうね
うん だからこの流れということをわかっておけば大丈夫なんですね
たとえ たとえとしてサッカー試合を考えましょう
ゴールの柵は固定しているならば
ボールを蹴ってポイントを取るのは簡単です
サッカー試合だったら
まあ一応ボールを柵に蹴るでしょうね
それでゴールでしょうね
はっきりしてますね ゴールは固定していますね
でも違うんです それだったら
あんな人々に簡単にゴール取れますよ
サッカー選手たちっていうのは
もう足の動きのあの微妙っていうか
すごいんですからね しかし
選手にとっては固定した道はありません
サッカーやってる人々には
ゴールは固定しているものじゃないんです
蹴れませんよ だからやっと試合終わるとと勝ったにしても
1対0とかね あるいは 1対1でももう引き分けとかね
大変ですよ この間 テレビでなんかある国の
あのサッカーのゴール蹴るのは見ていたんですけど
びっくりしたんです あのゴールキーパーと何人か待ってるのに
この人はいきなり遠いところから蹴ったんですね
蹴ったところはしっと計算すると
ゴールの上の横バーがありますね
ぴったしそれ狙ってるんです
どう見たっても これはこちらに行って上へ飛ぶんだよと
目で見ると でも読みが甘くて
そこをずっとバーを目掛けて来るんだけど
ここら辺になってくると見事にボールが落ちるんですよ
落ちてゴールになっちゃったんです
あの瞬間の読みなんですね
みんな読みが甘かったんです
これだったらもう瞬時ですからね
すごい早く打つんだ ボールも早いんだからね
でもそのあの瞬間に打った人はどれほど計算したかということなんです
それはコンピューターにはできん
計算してすごいスピードで打ったんです
打ったところで見たら
これはバーに当たって上へ飛ぶんだって言っても
あのエネルギーはちょうどそういうところで割ってるんです
ボールに与えたエネルギーはそこで落ちるんです
落ちるところはカーブで落ちるんだから
ゴールの中なんです それ見て私はまあこのアイデア
やっぱりゴールのたとえ考えたんです
いかに成功する人々ってすごいということなんです
だからゴールは固定しているならば
ゴールに打っちゃえばいいでしょうに
そうするとゴールキーパーと他の人と待ち構えていて捕るんですからね
ゴールにならないんです
ですから これぐらい人々は待っている
みんなプロでしょうし
どんなボールでも取るでしょうし
だから行くわけじゃないんですから
その条件に合わせたゴールなんです
だから物理的にゴールの柵が動きませんだけど
論理的には違うんです
人生どんな計画にしたっても
そういう風にゴールは固定してないんです
瞬間の出来事な瞬間でうまく終わっちゃうと結果ですよ
たとえボールが柵まで飛んでも
ゴールにならない場合が多いでしょうに
だからゴールのプロの人々っていうのは
あの四角い枠の中でどんなところにも打てますよ
それぐらい訓練はしています
それは固定した訓練で
しかし 実際の試合ではそこじゃないんですね
やっぱりまた違う それで相手にディフェンスするんだという仮定して
ディフェンスも慣れますけど
同じチーム同士だからね
同じチーム同士でやってますから
それももう 単なる訓練だけになるだけで
実際の試合ではもう同じチームじゃないんです
だからその場で判断するということは
そういう固定したスポーツの世界でも同じことなんです
無常です 人生のいくなる試合でも
一直線でゴールまではいけないんです
瞬間瞬間 我々はコースの調整をしなくてはならないんです
だから 何に何をやっても
いつでもあの調整 調整
調整 道を調整するということ必要なんです
最後の 1 秒で 最後の 1 センチでコースが変わってしまうこともあるんです
だから常に調整するという
これはもう医学の世界ででも
普通の経済世界ででも
どこでも スポーツでもどこでも同じなんですよ
まあ今までうまくいったんだからと思ったら
それは違うんです 最後の最後まで調整しなくちゃいけないんです
これが流動無常の真理です
それから何に注意するのか
そういうふうに仕事をする場合はね
ゴール 目的 期待 希望 願望
夢にばかり注意すると確実に負ける
失敗する ないんだから
そんなのはね 注意するべきなのはゴールではなく
そこまでたどらなくてはいけない道です
道だけに注意すれば 方法だけに注意すればいいんです
やり方だけに注意すればいいんです
それでも 経過した道は過去なので
それを気にすると危険です
時間の浪費です 今までうまくいったとかね
思った途端 次は失敗するんです
今まで順調だからと思った瞬間で
それはどうでもいいんです
今までの順調は次に気をつけなくちゃ
次に気をつけなくちゃと
終わるまで これからたどらなくてはならない道も将来です
仮定することしかできないものです
それから はい この調子でここまで行くぞと思っちゃうと
これもダメなんです 今やっていることをちゃんと調整して
今のことを調整する そちらにだけ注意するんです
これからこれもやって
あれもやって これもやって
これもやって 順調に無事完成するぞと思っちゃうと
将来のことだからね これまた失敗するんです
将来にばかり注意すると
また現象は固定しているという邪見に邪思に陥ってみじめな失敗する
まあ余計な考え方に 将来考えちゃうとまた失敗するんです
前の漢字も正しいみたいですけど
なんか勝手に思うことっていうことで
まあ辞書を調べて入れたんですけど
仏教専門用語じゃなくて
まあどうでもいいんですけど
別に この詩は仏教用語だからね
あれは一般的にいい加減で
自分の思惑というかね
少しいいっていうのはないです
こっちの悪い意味で使われる
まあこれはどうせ悪い意味で使いますからね
だからこのこれからやること言っちゃうと
これも悪い思考だから
結果がもう決まって悪くなるんですよ
それで失敗ということになるんだからね
だから今やってることは順調っていうことだけに調整すればいいんです
だからやりやすいんですよ
今のことだけ調整する
だから楽なんです そうするとなんか気分がいいんです
うまくいったんだから
それで全部プロセス経て終わるまで気持ちよくなるんですよ
長い時間かけてすごいことをやって終わっても
終わりましたよと そういう楽しみしか残らないんですよ
今実際に行っていることに注意するんですね
何に注意するべきかというと
今具体的に行っている行為は失敗なく完璧にやり遂げるのです
だから我々完璧にやるのは大胆なことじゃなくて
今のちょこっとしたことなんです
それだけは完璧にやってほしい
ほんのちょっとだからね
たったそれだけで全て完璧に行くんです
しかし 仏教の教えだからね
智慧っていうものは 理解能力っていうのは必要で
感情的な人間に 無知な人間に
投げやりな人間に理解できる世界でもないんです